I
last night 10 million people tuned into
the boys the see Blake Shelton and Gwen
Stefani performed their long away to
country do wet our so Keisha lacy was
backstage with Blake for the love story
behind the love song
the hardest part was it not smiling you
know throughout the whole thing when
we're singing it because it was just we
can't believe this is happening
when a blake nailed it in just two takes
last night the duet was shot in front of
a live audience an hour before the show
so here's what you didn't see they
looked amazing even for I'll actually
joked oh you guys look so cute
why don't you do it
the first time they ran through the song
Blake and Gwen were staring at each
other the whole time and at the end it
looked like Blake gave Gwen a little
kiss on the head that's not the take
they used in the show though we only
ended up seeing on TV Blake bowing down
to Gwen the couple caught a standing
ovation both times
and when we saw Blake before the show he
gave us the backstory to the great love
song when I originally started writing
this song that we're performing than
that I was only trying to impress when
that time around - it's funny because I
still discover songs that I know almost
by heart that I didn't even know she's
the one that sang them Hey Baby was the
last one that I was like that's you that
was y'all so also last night coach
christina aguilera debuted her lavender
locks
she'll reportedly be singing a special
duet of her own at the end of the season
with a hologram of the late Whitney
Houston I'm very excited about the
finale I'm not a very funny thing
happening with it would be tremendous if
it happened